[Applause]
give me one minute and i'll show you how
chronicle can detect security exploits
in your enterprise
let's say your colleague alex reports
encountering a suspicious domain that
asked for her corporate credentials
chronicle allows you to quickly search
your security telemetry for the
suspicious domain you can also find out
if other employees or assets have been
compromised by stitching correlated data
points into coherent events
chronicle makes sense of the massive
data to find vulnerabilities like
phishing malware and more sophisticated
patterns of attack
even if the phishing attack was
unnoticed by alex chronicle may have
alerted you about the exploit
chronicle detect integrates with
google's own threat intelligence as well
as third-party feeds to identify
well-known exploits
you can also migrate your existing
security rules from existing tools to
chronicle's expressive language
to use chronicle simply enable chronicle
for your gcp project in the console with
your one-time password
once enabled chronicles starts to ingest
your security locks at scale
so next time you're looking to detect
vulnerabilities across your fleet take a
minute to explore chronicle to learn
more check out cloud.google.com
chronicle
[Music]